[Música]
el senado de haití con apenas un tercio
de sus congresistas designó este viernes
a joseph lambert como nuevo presidente
interino tras el magnicidio de jouvenel
moix el primer ministro interino claude
joseph solicitó a naciones unidas y a
eeuu el envío de tropas para ayudar a
proteger la infraestructura clave pero
un alto funcionario estadounidense dijo
que washington no tiene planes de evitar
asistencia militar al país caribe
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
insistió a su homólogo ruso vladimir
putin que tome medidas contra los
ciberdelincuentes que actuar en su país
y dijo que su gobierno está listo para
responder a los ciberataques que según
denuncia se llevan a cabo desde rusia
según el último informe presentado por
la organización internacional oxfam el
hambre mata a más personas por minuto
que la pandemia de kobe 19 de acuerdo
con el documento alrededor de 155
millones de personas en todo el mundo
atraviesan niveles críticos de
inseguridad alimentaria lo que
representa 20 millones más que las
registradas el año pasado
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo en
france 24 los saluda andrés meza muñoz
iniciamos en haití donde el senado con
apenas un tercio de sus congresistas
designó este viernes a joseph lambert
como nuevo presidente interino tras el
magnicidio de llueve en el mois el
primer ministro interino solicitó a
naciones unidas y a eeuu el envío de
tropas para ayudar a proteger la
infraestructura clave pero según un alto
funcionario estadounidense
washington no tiene planes de brindar
asistencia militar al país caribeño
dos días después del asesinato de
jouvenel moix el senado de haití con
apenas un tercio de sus congresistas
nombró este viernes al titular de la
cámara alta joseph lambert como el nuevo
presidente provisional del país un claro
desafío al ejecutivo del primer ministro
interino claude joseph quien asumió el
poder con el respaldo de la policía y el
ejército no me interesa una lucha de
poder sólo hay una forma de llegar a la
presidencia en haití y es a través de
las elecciones la resolución del senado
que firmaron ocho diputados considera
que crouch yusef no puede estar en el
poder ya que fue cesado de su cargo el
pasado lunes en el último decreto
firmado por maurice así que proponen a
lambert como jefe de estado hasta el 7
de febrero de 2022 mientras el país se
sumerge en una nueva crisis política
el gobierno interino de kruschev
solicitó a la onu ya estados unidos el
envío de tropas para apoyar a la policía
nacional especialmente para la
protección de infraestructuras clave
definitivamente necesitamos asistencia y
hemos pedido ayuda
socios internacionales creemos que
nuestros socios pueden ayudar a la
policía nacional a resolver la situación
en respuesta un alto funcionario de la
administración estadounidense dijo que
eeuu no tiene planes de proporcionar
asistencia militar a haití en este
momento recalcó sin embargo que
washington está enviando funcionarios de
las fuerzas de seguridad y del fbi para
evaluar cómo puede ser útil
el presidente de estadounidense joe
biden insistió a su homólogo ruso
vladimir putin a tomar medidas contra
los ciberdelincuentes que actúan en su
país y reiteró que su gobierno está
listo para responder los ciberataques
que según denuncia se llevan a cabo
desde rusia la advertencia se da luego
de que una red de origen ruso
reivindicará un ataque contra la firma
tecnológica estadounidense casella que
afectó a unas 1500 empresas secundarias
deben actuar ese fue el mensaje del
presidente de eeuu joe biden durante una
llamada telefónica a su homólogo ruso
vladimir putin en el centro de la
conversación los ciberataques
le dejé muy claro que eeuu espera que
cuando las operaciones de rain software
vengan de su suelo aunque no estén
patrocinadas por el estado
esperemos que actúen si le damos
suficiente información que actúen sobre
quién es
está
en los últimos meses de eeuu ha sido
blanco de varios ataques de 'hackers' la
empresa de software castilla ha sido la
última víctima la semana pasada sufrió
un ataque de ransomware como resultado
más de 1500 empresas se vieron afectadas
en mayo la compañía petrolera colonial
pipeline también fue atacada el ataque
de ransomware provocó escasez de
combustible en ese país
los ataques suelen ser llevados a cabo
por hackers rusos sin embargo moscú ha
negado toda la responsabilidad la
ciberseguridad se ha convertido en la
última herida en las relaciones entre
eeuu y rusia durante su encuentro en
ginebra el pasado mes los dos jefes de
estado acordaron reunir expertos de
ambos países para resolver el problema a
principios de esta semana la casa blanca
dijo que estaba dispuesta a tomar
medidas si el gobierno ruso no puede o
no quiere tomar medidas contra los
actores criminales que residen en rusia
tomaremos medidas o nos reservaremos el
derecho de tomarlas por nuestra cuenta
el kremlin ha señalado de vuelta a eeuu
moscú dice que el gobierno de bailén
nunca le ha pedido ayuda para investigar
los recientes ataques pero washington lo
niega
han enviado múltiples solicitudes al
menos ocho personas murieron en la
capital de somalia tras la explosión de
un carro bomba contra un convoy del
gobierno éste transportaba a un alto
funcionario de la policía que según la
agencia oficial de noticias sobrevivió
al ataque se teme que el número de
víctimas mortales pueda incrementar por
la gravedad de los heridos el grupo
extremista al-shabab que busca derrocar
al gobierno se atribuyó la
responsabilidad del atentado
vamos a cuba porque la vacuna abdalá
recibió el visto bueno del regulador de
medicamentos para su uso de emergencia
contra el kobe 19 la aprobación del
fármaco que tiene una efectividad del 90
y 2.28 por ciento permitirá acelerar la
vacunación masiva en la isla en plena
crisis sanitaria así como exportar el
producto abdalá se convierta así en la
primera vacuna latinoamericana contra el
virus y varios países ha manifestado su
interés en producirla o adquirirla
aunque aún no cuenta con la aprobación
de la o ms
el hambre mata más personas que el cob y
19 así lo revela un nuevo informe
presentado por la organización contra la
pobreza oxfam que tiene como título el
virus del hambre se multiplica según el
estudio de oxfam 11 personas mueren de
hambre cada minuto en todo el mundo un
flagelo aún peor que el del joven 19 que
mata a 7 personas cada minuto veamos el
informe de roxana baspineiro
a poco más de un año desde que comenzara
la pandemia de kobe 19 las muertes por
hambre superan a las provocadas por el
virus así lo revela un informe de la
organización humanitaria oxfam las
cifras presentadas apuntan a que al
menos 11 personas mueren cada minuto por
el hambre extrema causada por la
combinación letal de conflictos armados
la crisis climática y el impacto dejado
por la pandemia en general 155 millones
de personas en todo el mundo viven ahora
en niveles de crisis de inseguridad
alimentaria o peor es decir 20 millones
más que el año pasado el informe también
enumera los países denominados como los
peores sitios de hambre entre los cuales
figuran afganistán etiopía sudán del sur
siria y yemen todos ellos envueltos en
conflictos armados el hambre sigue
sirviendo como arma de guerra que priva
a los civiles de alimentos y agua y
obstaculiza la ayuda humanitaria la
gente no puede vivir con seguridad ni
encontrar alimentos cuando sus mercados
son bombardeados y las cosechas y el
ganado son
y la organización instó a los gobiernos
a actuar con urgencia para abordar la
inseguridad alimentaria y sus causas
resaltando al mismo tiempo que el gasto
militar mundial aumentó en 51.000
millones de dólares durante la pandemia
una cantidad seis veces superior al
presupuesto que la onu necesita para
acabar con el hambre
el festival de cannes continúa
presentando lo mejor del cine
internacional en la costa azul la
película mexicana la civil que aborda el
tema del feminicidio fue ovacionada por
el público este viernes hoy compite en
la película finlandesa el compartimento
número 6 y el día de la bandera del
estadounidense champ en nuestra enviada
especial erika olavarría tiene los
detalles en el siguiente informe la
competencia oficial continúa hoy en
cannes como todos los días con dos
películas un filme finlandés y el
regreso aquí a la coser del actor y
director estadounidense sean penn que
viene con una película filmada junto a
dos de sus hijos pero aquí en cannes
estamos todavía con resaca de ayer por
la presentación de benedetta la película
del holandés paul a ver joven una
película que impactó no por la temática
que ella es polémica los amores
homosexuales de una monja en el siglo 17
en italia sino por la manera en que está
filmada y como mezcla el drama con
escenas de comedia que descolocaron al
público sino hoy también se presenta una
película latinoamericana en la sección
una cierta mirada la civil es en
realidad la película de una directora
humana pero hecha en mexico con una
temática muy mexicana como es el
secuestro de una adolescente por el
narcotráfico una adolescente que es
buscada por su madre
hasta aquí este informativo en france 24
piense con nosotros
[Música]